Recall the five rules of message passing
and consider the following scenario.
Suppose I have a linear
network of eight nodes.
So suppose that node zero wants
to send a message to node two,
at exactly the same time that node six
wants to send a message to node three.
How much time will it take for these
two simultaneous messages to transpire?
Here's the path from
node zero to node two and
here's the path from
node six to node three.
Notice that these messages occupy
independent paths in the network,
therefore, they can
happen simultaneously.
So if the messages are both of size n
then the time is just alpha plus beta
times n.
Now I want you to try.